Hi, everyone.
Hello.
Welcome to the Experimental Therapy session.
Good evening. My name is
Ahmed Aman.
I'm going to be the
co-chair of the session
with Elena. I am coming from Ontario Institute for Cancer
Research, which is located in Toronto, Canada.
So,
I'll say a few words later, but Elena?
Thank you very much. I'm Elena Garralda.
I'm a medical oncologist in Vall d'Hebron Hospital in Barcelona, Spain.
Great. So that's us. So if you go to the
next slide deck.
There. So we are going to
hear today about tumor microenvironment, immune modulation,
and
drug delivery, nanoparticle formulation, and tumor
models. Okay? So this is a diverse topic,
but they are, I think, very important for discovery.
And obviously, I think tumor microenvironment, you cannot say
enough of it. There are so many talks this year.
This is a very important topic. And then drug
delivery, nanoparticle formulation is also very, very
important and up and coming. And then we'll hear at the
end a
talk about the 3D models, and that is also very
exciting.
People are going away from 2D model, going to 3D model, and that is very
exciting, and we'll hear about that, too.
So
that is the
overall overview of the session.
We'll have seven talks in the session.
Each talk is 10 minutes, and then there'll be five minutes Q&A
after that.
And then at the end, actually, Elena is going to summarize
the talks we just heard, and we can have some discussion at the time, too.
Okay? So let's begin.
So
our first speaker is Dr. Seela Singh.
She's coming from Canada. So
welcome, Seela.
Thank you very much. Good afternoon, everyone.
I want to thank the organizers for the privilege of giving this talk.
Oops.
There we go. These are my disclosures.
It's a little slow. I'll use this.
Yeah.
Okay. Many of us were very hopeful that CAR T-cell
therapy could change outcomes for patients with glioblastoma.
Glioblastoma, of course, is the most common primary adult
brain tumor, and it is currently incurable.
And you can see here that the standard of care really does fail these
patients, as the five-year survivorship is only 5%.
And we know that this graph shows that the
global number of CAR T-cell trials across solid tumors, you can see the
gliomas lead the way. But unfortunately, most CAR T-cell trials in
glioblastoma have failed to produce long-standing remission.
An important reason for this is because GBM is not purely a tumor cell
autonomous disease. This lesion that we see on this MRI represents a
complex ecosystem, which is composed of not only malignant cells, but
macrophages, glia, vessels, stromal populations.
Among all of the non-malignant populations, we think macrophages are especially
important because they're really the most dominant faction within the GBM
microenvironment, particularly at recurrence.
And we see this across single cell--
or rather, the reason for this really is that we see that GBM is
across these single cell data sets, there's tumor-associated macrophages, or
TAMs, that almost always numerically dominate, and their
pro-tumorigenic roles are now very well understood.
But for adoptive cell therapy in particular, they represent a really major
barrier because they're abundant, they're immunosuppressive, and they're typically
not engaged by conventional tumor-restricted CAR designs.
A second critical compartment is the glioma stem cell population.
And glioma stem cells we know sit high on the tumor hierarchy.
They cycle between cellular states, and they contribute
disproportionately to treatment resistance and relapse.
And we think that glioma stem cells do not operate in isolation.
In fact, they participate in reciprocal crosstalk with TAMs, raising the
possibility that the glioma stem cell tumor-associated macrophage axis
may itself be a tractable therapeutic vulnerability.
To interrogate this axis directly, we established some in vitro heterospheroids
combining glioma stem cells isolated from a recurrent glioblastoma's
patient's tumor, which is BT972, along with
THP-1 macrophage-like cells, and we followed this with single-cell
transcriptomic analysis. And this system allowed us to ask how each compartment
is rewired by exposure to the other cell type by examining changes in gene
expression in the co-culture condition compared to each cell's monoculture.
If we look specifically at genes upregulated in both compartments after co-culture,
they could mark shared tumor myeloid biology that provides a more meaningful
therapeutic entry point rather than genes that are only expressed in one cell
type. And these genes emerge from myeloid interactions that we know are very
important. And so from these reciprocally induced genes,
GPNMB was one of the most compelling co-responsive candidates,
raising the possibility that we might be able to co-target glioma stem cells and
tumor-associated macrophages through a single
antigen.GPNMB,
or glycoprotein non-metastatic protein B, is a heavily
glycosylated type one transmembrane protein.
And in cancer, GPNMB supports migration invasion through its RGD integrin
interactions and downstream kinase signaling.
And recent literature has demonstrated that GPNMB is involved in the crosstalk
between cancer cells and tumor-associated macrophages, just like what
we found in our heterospheroid assays.
And it's a marker for pro-tumorigenic macrophage states.
But none of the prior literature has explored targeting GPNMB as a
potential strategy to kill two birds with one stone.
We asked if GPNMB has sufficient clinical relevance to justify this
therapeutic development, and we can see that it's certainly upregulated in GBM
RNA-seq data compared to normal tissue.
At the protein level, it's detectable across the cell surface of multiple
patient-derived glioma stem cell lines, but critically absent from
healthy neural stem cells and astrocytes.
And proteomics and immunohistochemistry also show that it's further increased
in recurrent compared to primary disease.
We wanted to know whether GPNMB was functionally relevant, so we used CRISPR
knockout in multiple patient-derived glioma stem cell models and found that
GPNMB perturbation reduces proliferation and prolongs survival in
orthotopic mouse experiments. So really, GPNMB does seem to
support glioma growth intrinsically.
If we compare the cell states of our GPNMB knockout tumors, and here
you can see that we did single-cell, rather RNA sequencing analysis, you can
see that they shift towards developmental states
rather than the more aggressive, most aggressive mesenchymal state.
And specifically, we saw enrichments of the OPC-like and the MPC-like and
astrocyte-like states without enrichment of mesenchymal programs.
And so this places GPNMB in a tumor state that we think is
microenvironmentally engaged and correlated with more aggressive
disease behavior. Across independent single-cell data sets,
GPNMB signal localizes very strongly to the myeloid compartment, which
you can see here.
So how can we target GPNMB? Well, it was actually initially
characterized and targeted in melanoma and breast cancer, some more than
a decade ago, through an antibody drug conjugate, which is called
blenzetumumab. And unfortunately, the ADC was pulled from trial due
to skin toxicity. And we also know that ADC
delivery is rather difficult in the setting of GBM, and often they have poor
CNS penetrance. So while we were studying GPNMB and GBM, our
collaborator at the University of Calgary, Doug Mahoney, was also exploring it as a
target for other solid tumors, including osteogenic sarcoma.
And they had cloned the already validated
CDX011 binder from the ADC into a second-generation CAR
vector, and they actually went further by getting Health Canada approval to
perform a first-in-human trial in a patient with metastatic sarcoma.
And they found the CAR was very effective at controlling some of the smaller
pulmonary metastases. But most importantly, the IV-infused
GPNMB CAR Ts were very well tolerated with just a grade 1 rash that
was well controlled with topical steroids, unlike the findings from the ADC
trials. And so we thought this would translate very well for GBM.
So we tested the anti-GPNMB CAR T cells in vitro against glioma stem
cells. We found excellent cytotoxicity, activation,
cytokine release, and also confirmed antigen
specificity. But when we went in vivo with the CARs in
our patient-derived xenograft models, we were very pleasantly surprised
to see that two intracranial doses of one million CAR T cells produced
complete tumor clearance and durable disease
control. Of course, PDXs in NOD scid mice are
largely devoid of functional macrophages, although there are some that stain with
IBA
1 and 2. So we still had to answer if the GPNMB CAR T cells could
meaningfully engage the myeloid compartment.
So within the tumor microenvironment, macrophages obviously exist in heterogeneous
cell states, some of which are actually immunostimulatory and anti-tumor.
So we tried to model this by exposing U937 macrophages to various
stimuli. So PMA can differentiate monocytes into
macrophages, and interferon gamma will induce a more anti-tumor
interferon-activated phenotype, which is historically like an M1
macrophage. But to make M2-like immunosuppressive macrophages,
we exposed U937s to a cocktail of IL4, IL10,
and TGF-beta. And so we took the tumor condition media from glioma stem
cells and supplemented the macrophages with it.
And we performed flow characterization for surface GPNMB across these states.
And we found that GPNMB was highest in the macrophages exposed
to the immunosuppressive cytokines and lowest in the more M1-like
macrophages. And we saw that the GPNMB CAR T cells
consistent with that preferentially lyse the immunoregulatory,
immunosuppressive macrophages while sparing the interferon gamma
prime macrophages. And we wondered if these immunoregulatory
macrophages could suppress CAR T cytotoxicity against glioma stem
cells or if the CAR Ts can overcome this.
And so we set up this triple co-culture with glioma stem cells,
M2-like U937s, and the T cells, and we measured the viability of
each cell type after 24 hours, and we found indeed that the CAR T
cells do kill both the glioma stem cells and the
U937s.
We also tested this effect in vivo in a macrophage-rich intracranial
setting by co-inoculating
GBM8 cells with the immunosuppressive cytokine-conditioned
U937s. And then we treated with CAR Ts.
And you can see here that we found macrophage-containing tumors actually grow
much faster and have a much shorter survival if you compare the yellow
and the pink lines to the black and blue.
And you can see the U937-containing tumors are over tenfold the size of the
GBM8-only tumors. And even in this enforced myeloid
context, GPNMB CAR T treatment induced a profound
regression and caused really good survival and clearance
of both the GPNMB-positive tumor cells and the GPNMB-positive
macrophages in vivo.But because xenograft
models are limited in their ability to model the immune microenvironment,
we wanted to test the anti-GPNNB therapy in an immunocompetent
setting. And so to this end, our colleagues in Calgary generated a
murinized anti-mouse GPNNB CAR using a binder available from a
commercial antibody. And then we tested them against the syngeneic
GL261 model, and we really did see the same excellent
effects and very good remission in vivo.
And we did not see any toxicity in these mice, and importantly, not skin
toxicity.
And this is really just a whole mount IF slide to show you a spatial readout of the
same result. And in the treated brains, you can see the tumor signal is essentially
eliminated, and there's clear depletion of the GPNNB-positive macrophages
alongside tumor clearance.
So to conclude, our data identify GPNNB as a therapeutically
tractable antigen in GBM that is shared across malignant cells and
TAMs. And the success of this CAR T suggests that durable
control of GBM in a long-term will really require us to co-target both
compartments of the disease. And really, this gives us a way to operationalize
this concept with a single CAR T product.
We believe this is the first dual-compartment targeting CAR T tested in
glioblastoma, aside from the cell paper that came out of
Scott Lowe and Michel Vesole's programs last week, where they showed a
uPAR targeting CAR T accomplishes the same in PDAC.
So on that note, I just want to finish and
thank the wonderful students and postdocs who were the first authors on
this paper, Dr. Neil Savage,
MD, PhD candidate Sean Grewal, and Dr.
Vaseem Shaikh, as well as all of our wonderful collaborators.
I'm happy to take questions.
Hi. Wonderful talk.
Thank you.
So I had a quick question. So you did identify, and also it has been shown, GPNNB
gets upregulated in GBM. So I was wondering if you looked into the
downstream pathways in these cell lines, which might be getting
activated?
Yeah. So actually, the downstream signaling pathways are very similar to those that
we see activated in melanoma and in other mesenchymal cancers.
So we didn't put much of that into this paper because it was really the same as
previously described.
Perfect. Thank you.
Ashlee, great talk.
Thank you.
Questions.
So first, in your syngeneic
model, once you treat these tumors, did you have the opportunity to
look at their immune compartment?
Had it been reprogrammed to a more immune,
active
milieu due to the targeting of the M2 macrophages?
Yes, we were. So we actually were able to do some spatial biology.
It was Amy Heimberger's lab, who very kindly provided the Lunaphore platform for us
to assess quantitatively the different immune cell compartments.
But in full disclosure, I'll tell you it was a very difficult experiment to run.
We did it with humanized mice as well, and the problem is figuring out the right
time points to sacrifice the mice, because I think in the first few runs of
the experiments, we missed the immune activation states.
I would imagine.
So yeah.
I'm sure that would be definitely a problem.
Second question, just two-part. One, did you see any
escape of the tumor cells because they lost the expression of the
antigen? And
but because you had reprogrammed the immunosuppression, have you considered
combining it with any kind of checkpoint inhibitor so that you
could maybe prevent immune evasion?
Yeah, these are excellent questions.
So we do see in experiments where...
So you saw that most of the mice had tumor clearance, which was wonderful, and
they actually survived
durably. But the mice that did succumb, there were a few mice that succumbed to
tumor, and we did see GPNNB antigen escape.
And so it really brings to light the fact that we're going to have to treat
glioblastoma with polytherapy.
Sounds great. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Over here. David Kirsch from Princess Margaret Cancer Center in Toronto.
Oh, hi.
Really wonderful work. I'm wondering if you could expand a little bit more on
other tumor types where this protein's expressed, and
also comment on where else it's expressed in normal
tissues in humans.
Absolutely. So where we see it in terms of normal tissue
expression is obviously mostly skin.
And so in my colleague, Doug Mahoney's paper, they actually
humanized mice to really do the toxicity testing and show
that there were some minimal skin effects, but they were controlled.
And then in terms of where it's expressed in other cancers, my friend Peter Siegel
at McGill University in Canada actually has studied for a
very long time GPNNB's expression in more
fibrolytic breast cancer subtypes.
And so it really is a marker of mesenchymal state.
So you're going to find it in osteogenic sarcoma, melanoma,
any cell that has a mesenchymal cell of origin.
Thank you.
Wonderful talk.
David. Thank you.
Just wondering, when it's in the cells it's overexpressed in, is there
phospho proteomics or intracellular targets that are overexpressed
or activated that could be
targets for drugs that could be used in tandem with the CAR T?
It's an excellent question, David, and we haven't done phospho proteomics yet
on, for example, GPNNB sorted cells, but I think it's a great
suggestion. We also originally found that
GPNNB was upregulated in the population of tumor cells
post-treatment with our CD133 CAR T-cell, which we actually published
on
in 2020. And so I think that there is an argument to
combine this CAR T-cell with another therapeutic, and it would be best if it were
rationally combined. So I think it's a great suggestion.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
In the interest of time, we have no more questions. Please go ahead.
Okay. Thank you very much for that wonderful presentation.
Now, I'm going to invite our second speaker today, Yue Xu, talking
about tumor-tailored lipid nanoparticles facilitating IL-2
circular RNA delivery for lung cancer immunotherapy.
Hello, good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you to the section chairs and AACR for the opportunity to present
my work today. My name is Yue Xu from the Baylor College of Medicine.
This work I will be sharing introduces a tumor-targeted ionizable lipid
nanoparticles platform
that delivers IL-12 circRNA for lung cancer
immunotherapy. This study was carried out at the University of Toronto
and published in "Advanced Materials" in 2024.
And this slide,
listing my disclosures. I have no relevant financial
relationships to disclose.
Let me start with the rationale for using circRNA
as a therapeutic modality. Over the past five years,
linear mRNA has transformed the
vaccine development and opened the door to a broad
class of RNA therapeutics. But when we move from SARS-CoV
vaccine into oncology, the requirements
change a lot. For tumor immunotherapy, we need sustained local protein
expression.
Linear mRNA has three fundamental limitations that makes
this difficult. It's unstable and short-lived expression and require
extra chemical modification like 5-prime capping to
avoid the innate immune sensing.
circRNA offers a way around each of these,
because both ends of the molecule are covalently joined.
It is resistant to enzyme degradation, and
this translates into three practical advantages that are
directly relevant to cancer therapy.
First thing is the persistent
protein expression in vivo. The second thing is robust thermal stability, and the
third thing is a simple manufacturing process.
No 5-prime capping, no 3-prime tearing, and
no need for extra chemical modification.
Together, these features support better efficacy, a
potentially improved safety profile, lower cost of goods,
and easier logistics. So conceptually,
circRNA is a well-matched cargo for cytokine-based immunotherapy,
where we want durable localized expression at the tumor site.
So the question is, why we choose IL-12 as our cargo?
The payload we choose is IL-12. IL-12 is a cytokine
composed of p35 and p40
subunit, and it is the most potent
pro-inflammatory cytokine in cancer immunotherapy.
As shown in the figure, IL-12 acts on
multiple arms of the immune system at the same time.
It activates CD8 T cells and NK cells, drives the
interferon gamma production, promotes Th1 polarization, and
reprograms the myeloid compartment in the tumor
microenvironment. In the preclinical models, recombinant IL-12
has produced some of the most dramatic anti-tumor responses ever
reported. And yet, despite more than two decades of the
clinical efforts, IL-12 has been
successfully translated in the clinical. The reason is well-known.
Systemic recombinant IL-12 is associated with serious toxicity
due to off-target immune activation.
The therapeutic window is
extremely narrow. So the central question of this work
is, can we retain the anti-tumor potency of IL-12 while
confining the effectivity to the tumor?
Our hypothesis is that delivery of the IL-12 in
the form of circRNA encapsulated into a tumor-targeted
ionizable lipid nanoparticle can achieve this therapeutic window.
So
this slide layouts the overall concept.
We encapsulate the IL-12 circRNA into our ionizable lipid
nanoparticle. The lipid nanoparticle is
delivered locally, either by the tumor injection for subcutaneous tumor
or by intratracheal injection for lung tumors.
Once taken up by the cells, the site of the delivery, the circRNA is
translated into functional IL-12, which is secreted in the local
tumor microenvironment. So we have three questions here to answer.
The first question is, can we make pure functional IL-12 circRNA at
scale?
The second question is here, can we identify a lipid nanoparticle formulation
that is optimized for circRNA delivery?
The last question is, does this combination actually work
both as monotherapy and in
combination with immune checkpoint blockade?
So first, we do the
circRNA production. We use the PIE strategy, which allow
self-splicing circulation of an IVT
precursor. The constructor is designed so that
the IVT derives translation of the IL-12
p35 and p40 subunits from the circular format, yielding a
back to p70 format. A critical challenge with
circRNA is purity. The IVT reaction
produce a mixture of circular products, unreacted
linear precursor, and nicked intermediates.
These side products are not inert.
They trigger the innate immune sensing and then compromising the
reproducibility. So we develop a size
exclusion HPLC purification protocol.
As seen in the panel B,
you can see a clean separation of circRNA IL-12 from the
surrounding species. We collected the vials one
through the vials eight across the main peak.
Panel C shows the gel analysis of these fractions.
The lower band is the purified IL-12 circRNA, and the
upside products... were extruded.
This step is what gives us a reproducible cargo to
downstream work.
Secondly, we want to use our delivery system for
this specific RTL of circRNA. CircRNA is chemically
distinct from the linear RNA. It has no 5 prime cap,
no poly-A tail, and therefore different physical properties.
So even nanoparticles optimized for mRNA are not optimal for
circRNA. We therefore build our own ionizable lipid library
specific for the circRNA delivery.
We use the four component reaction called a OB as a
combinatorial chemistry platform.
As shown in this panel, the four building blocks are AMI
group, an isocyanate linker, and two lipid tails
contributed by caprylic acid and an aldehyde.
This gives us the module high throughput methods overnight synthesis at
room temperature in ethanol to generate a chemical diverse lipid
library.
Panel B shows the specific building blocks we used.
Two AMI
head groups, three isocyanate links, four caprylic acid tails, and
four aldehyde tails. Combinatorial assembly give us a
matrix of candidates on ionizable lipids, each of which
we formulate into a four-component lipid nanoparticles, ionizable lipid,
tail lipid, cholesterol, and the PEG lipid 2000.
Encapsulating a FLOC circRNA reporter, we then
screen the entire library in vivo for protein expression.
The heat map on the right summarizes the output.
The top-performing lipid, we name it
H1AL1A1B3, combines the H1 head groups,
the HL1 linker, and the A1 caprylic acid.
And the
B3 aldehyde tails is the formulation we carried forward for
subsequent experiments.
With the lipid nanoparticle in hand, we next ask whether
circRNA actually delivers the kinetic advantage that we
hypothesized. We compared the R12 circRNA
to R12 mRNA, both formulated in the same lipid
nanoparticles. The left two panels show in vitro
kinetics in two lung cancer cell lines, A549 and
HKP1, for R12 mRNA. R12 protein in
the supernatant peaks on day one, and
falls below the detection limit by day three to day
four. In contrast, R12 circRNA maintains R12
concentration about 500 picograms
per milliliter out to day six or seven,
roughly a two-fold expression of the expression window.
The in vivo kinetic on the right panel,
measured by the FLOC bioluminescence after the intramuscular injection
at 48 hours. The FLOC signal from the circRNA group
is significantly higher than from the mRNA group.
So the kinetic benefits of circRNA is real.
It's
reproducible across the system, and it's most important
prominent at the later time points, which is
exactly where it matters for sustained immunotherapy.
So now we move to the efficacy. We first test
the platform in the Lewis lung carcinoma, or
LLC-1, subcutaneous models. The designs shown in the panel
A, mice was incorporated on the day one.
It received a single intra-tumoral dose of five micrograms of
R12 circRNA-lipid nanoparticles on day seven.
An Anti-PD-L1 antibody used the IP injection on day 10 and
the 13th. Panel B shows the tumor growth curves
for the five groups. First group is untreated one, second group
is scrambled circRNA-LNP, and the third one is the R12
circRNA-LNP monotherapy, and the last one is antibody PD-L1
mersibi, and the control.
We use both of them as a combination.
Two points are worth highlighting.
First is the anti-PD-L1 immunotherapy in LLC-1 is
essentially ineffective. The yellow curve tracks almost
identically with untreated and scrambled control, consistent with
the LLC-1 being a well-documented immune code checkpoint resident
model.
And the second
R12 circRNA monotherapy alone produced a robust, durable
tumor
regression. And the combination of the R12 circRNA plus anti-PD-L1
is superior still. New complete control of
tumor volume out of day 13. Plan C shows the body
weight with a simple readout of a systematic toxic.
Now the treatment group, including combination, shows the weight loss.
It's meaningful,
means the systematic R12 produced rapid and serious weight loss.
Local circRNA delivery preserves the
efficacy without a toxicity signal.
So to understand the mechanism, we provide the tumor
microenvironment at the serial
level by the flow cytometry and the immunofluorescence.
The flow panel on the up left shows CD45
positive infiltrate. It increased from
1.8% in the untreated group to the
13% with R12 circRNA monotherapy, and then to
24.6% with the combination, breaking that data
down by the subset. The bar graph shows a significant combination-driven
increase in CD8 T cells, CD4 T cells, and NKT
cells and monocytes. The immunofluorescence at the bottom confirms
this is a tissue level in the R12 circRNA plus
anti-PD-L1 group. You see a dense infiltrate of the CD
positive cells co-expressing interferon gamma throughout the
tumor. So the result demonstrates at the local R12
circRNA program an immune code of tumor in a
inflammatory T cell inflammatory tumor.
This is now responsive to PD-L1
blockade.The LS1
subcutaneous model is used for proof of concept, but lung cancer
is not a subcutaneous disease. To test the clinical relevance, we moved to
KRAS-driven non-small cell lung cancer model using
the HKP1 cells through the IV injection.
The key question is how do we deliver
IL-12/circRNA-LMP directly into the lung
by intratracheal and the actual local expression at the
tumor site? The design is showing in the panel A, HKP1 was dosed at
day one, a single five microgram intratracheal dose of
IL-12/circRNA-LMP on day nine. We then tracked tumor
burden by luminescence imaging on day nine, day 14,
and day 19. Panel B shows the representative
ILS images and the panel C, the quantification on day nine, the
day of the dosing, all groups comparable as expected.
By day 14 and day 19, the IL-12/circRNA-LMP
group shows a greater reduction in tumor region of the interest.
The scrambled circRNA-LMP control tracks with the untreated,
confirming that effect here is the IL-12 specific.
So a critical concern for any IL-12 therapy is
systematic cytokine exposure. We measure a
19 cytokine panel in serum on day one, day five after
intratracheal dosing. The heat map tells the
story. On day one, all results across three groups,
untreated, scrambled circRNA, and IL-12 circRNA
are at baseline. Even IL-12 p17 itself is
not detectable systematically on day one.
By day five, we're seeing a sharp target increase in certain
IL-12 p20 in the IL-12 circRNA group.
Consistent with durable circRNA expression and modest secondary
evaluation in
interferon gamma-related cytokine such as IL-12/10,
which expected a downstream biology.
Crucially, the classic toxic drivers, TNF alpha,
IL interferon 6, and interferon 1-beta
remain at all new baseline. It is a
favorable safety signature. On the right panel,
the flow plots should local immune recruitment in the lung,
CD45 positive cells. Frequency
rise from the roughly 31% in the untreated
and scrambled control to 55% in the IL-12 circRNA
group.
So finally, the slides integrates
the mechanism and the endpoint for the tumor model.
The left panel shows the immune cell quantification per milligram of
the lung tissue. In the IL-12 circRNA treated
group, CD45 positive cells rise sharply, roughly
double. NKT cells, nearly triple.
And the monocyte rise significantly, all relatives, the untreated, and the
scrambled controls. The CD8 to Treg ratio
climbs to around 35. On the right panel, the
gross lung images and the histology tell a clean story.
Untreated and the
scrambled control lungs are largely replaced by the tumor, with roughly 60% of
total tissue area occupied by the tumor cell.
So thanks to my previous lab at the
University of Toronto in the Borley Lab and my current lab, Yong Li
from the Baylor College of Medicine. I'm free to take any questions.
Thank you very much. Unfortunately, we've been running a bit over time with the
presentation, so if there's any questions, you can perhaps discuss them after
the session.
Okay.
And we're going to be moving smoothly to our next presenter.
Great. Thank you very much. So our next presenter is Faith
Barnett,
and they are going to talk about tumor-associated
macrophage,
new target, novel therapy.
Let's
see.
Thank you for this opportunity,
as I will be telling you about our approach,
which is a novel tumor-associated macrophage-targeted therapeutic for the
treatment of solid tumors. And my disclosures are I am the
founder and CSO of Resolute Science.
Our grant support has been through NCI and CureBon
Catalyst grants. So our technology, we
believe, will make the deadliest cancers treatable.
And it's somewhat of a common theme.
The most aggressive cancers have a high prevalence of tumor-associated
macrophages, or TAMs. Now, you see in the diagram in gold is the
TAMs, and in gray is the cancer cells.
And the TAMs are interdigitated throughout the cancer.
They can make up 30% to 50% or more of the cells in a cancer.
Now, as we know, in general, they promote tumor growth and
metastasis.
So many of the approaches have been to try and
eliminate the TAMs or change their phenotype back to tumor killing.
That approach hasn't worked. We took a very different approach,
and we just use what TAMs do very well naturally.
We use the TAMs
where they are in the tumor to receive, process, and deliver
cancer-killing agents. So in our hands, the more TAMs in
a tumor, the better.
In short, our approach, our drug called a
macrophage-targeted conjugate or MAC-TACs, make TAMs druggable
targets.
So this is immunohistochemistry. Brown is our targeted receptor.
Across the top, you have four subtypes of sarcoma.
And we believe that this uniform distribution
of TAMs, which is the targeted receptor
on the TAM in brown,
four subtypes of sarcoma, then you have gastric, prostate, triple-negative breast
cancer, brain metastasis, pancreatic, melanoma, bladder,
and squamous cell. And you can imagine that if you
can target... the receptor, the brown receptor
on these different tumor types,
you can treat many different types of cancer with a single drug.
So this is the prototype drug. It's modular in
design. The blue is the TAM-targeting ligand.
The backbone is gray. The linker, which can be cleavable or
non-cleavable,
and then you have the payload. Now, the payloads can be
cytotoxics, radioisotopes, or imaging agents.
It's 18 times smaller than an antibody-drug conjugate, which really
improves the delivery into the tumor, and
it stays in the tumor. But different than an ADC, it clears the
body quickly, and the plasma in about eight hours.
We avoid many of the common resistance mechanisms by targeting a TAM
rather than a mutating cancer cell receptor
or cancer cell. And we also have the ability to treat
CNS metastases. So
what you have is three therapeutics in the top.
Our lead therapeutic is RS5 carrying MMAE.
We have a second cytotoxic program, and then we have a radioisotope
program.
We have on the bottom surrogate imaging agents.
Now, I call them surrogate. They have clinical benefit in and of themselves,
but we use them to show where the therapeutics are going
or where we think the therapeutics are going.
So the FITC is on the next slide. So that is
fluorescein attached to the same prototype molecule.
So here you have it. It has a non-cleavable linker, so it's going to stay inside
the TAM. On the left, you have the tumor, and this is
representative of tumors across eye tumors, brain
tumors, and subcu tumors. We see a similar pattern of
uptake into the tumor. You see it, in the
green, traveling through the blood vessels. It does not stick to the blood vessels.
It just travels through them, and then it gets into the microcirculation of the
tumor, which you see in bright green. And that's five minutes after IV injection.
To the right, you see them inside the tumor, but
not inside the normal tissue. So you're getting the tumor specificity.
Now, importantly, this is a non-cleavable linker, so it
gets locked inside the TAM.
So this is our mechanism of action. It's a cartoon animation.
On the bottom, you have
our lead therapeutic with a cleavable linker, and here it goes.
It attaches to the receptor. The whole thing gets internalized
within minutes.
The receptor recycles back to the surface in
minutes.
Within the lysosome, in the dotted lines, you have cleavage of
the cytotoxic, which is hydrophobic, and it
passes into the neighboring tumor cell or is exocytosed
into the neighboring tumor cell. Now you get
cytotoxic
accumulating in the cancer cell. It kills the cancer cell.
Now, importantly, the TAM is relatively
unaffected by the MMAE. It is
non-dividing. So in an IC50 study
from 0.01 to 100 micromolar, we only lost 20% of the
TAMs. So the TAMs stay in the tumor to repeat the process.
It's iterative. The TAMs are also constantly being
replenished from the circulating monocytes.
So,
this is the first anti-cancer efficacy study we did.
It's a subcu in black. You have saline. In red, you have our drug.
On the right, you have large tumors on the top row.
After saline treatment on the bottom row, you have mostly just scar
tissue. Then you have melanoma. You have blue
is saline, red is our drug.
Body weight on the right, again, is generally stable.
Here is an aggressive doxorubicin-resistant
PDX model, and in the patient, it was
doxorubicin resistant. In the mouse, it's doxorubicin resistant.
You see it here in gold is the doxorubicin, in black is the saline, and
red is our drug. There was no tumor at end of study.
We took the same model and did a dose response with saline on
the top row, 2 mgs per kg, 4, 8, and 10.
And what you can see is 4, 8, and 10
all had strong anti-cancer efficacy, and it was
well-tolerated in all the different treatment groups.
So we did it in brain tumor model.
Luciferase is on the top row. That's the start of treatment.
At the bottom row is after two IV doses of our drug.
It's a dramatic
reduction in tumor size. And the controls
all died within two days of day 10, which was
our day we see the response. This is in
a
glioblastoma intracranial model.
It's a Kaplan-Meier survival curve, and this just shows that the drug does get
into the brain. It does not cure them, but it extends
survival by about 79%. We are now testing
this with radiation because MMAE is a radiation
sensitizer.
We then tried it in bigger tumors, as you see here.
We started with suboptimal dosing at 2.5 mgs per kg.
These are the individual mice, and you see about half of
them took off and started growing very quickly.
And we waited, and then at about 15 to 1,600
millimeters cubed, we increased the dose to 10 mgs per kg,
and we saw that all the tumors came down.
When we took out the tumors at the end of study,
even the ones that still had some bulk to them, it was
really fibrotic mass. We did not see evidence of residual tumor
cells.
So we are moving into the clinic in the end of this
year, and we wanted to see could we get down to once-a-week
dosing to make it more convenient for patients.So
these are the individual mice with saline,
and this is twice a week dosing, which we knew would work
well.
We then tried it at once a week dosing, and we were able to
get down to once a week dosing. And then surprisingly, we were also
able to get down to once every two week dosing in this model.
We've done another even more aggressive model, and we can also get
to once a week dosing with strong anticancer efficacy.
And the body weight is stable. The CBC and the chemistry
panels are all within normal limits in all the different treatment groups.
So in summary, we have a pan-cancer platform for solid
tumors across 22
studies, 10 different models.
We use the abundant TAMS in tumors to receive, process, and deliver
cytotoxic agents.
We avoid many drug resistance mechanisms.
It is brain tumor penetrant. We've received orphan drug
designation for soft tissue sarcomas.
We are planning an all-comers dose escalation study in
the beginning of 2027.
And I'm happy to take any questions.
Hi.
Wonderful talk. So,
I'm wondering what is the resistance mechanism
of this drug? Because it's in the U87 models,
clearly diminished the tumor in the day 10,
but you didn't get this complete remission case.
So what was the resistance mechanism?
Yeah. So in the subcu,
it kills the tumors. In the brain, it doesn't.
It sort of extends survival.
I think there's a lot of, when you look at the immunochemistry in
these tumors, what you see is a rearrangement in what we believe is this
microcirculation within the tumor, and you start to see
bigger angiogenic vessels. We thought that it might have to do
with MDR1 and
drug efflux pumps, which we also think is a problem.
And so we're trying to figure that out.
We're also going to be trying it with different cytotoxics.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi, thanks for this talk. Can you please elaborate more on the
structure of the molecule? How many payloads do you have?
Is it just one?
So it's about 1.4. What you have is the
backbone is
a polymer, so it's not identical in
size. So we have about one to 1.4. So it's a
variable payload,
DAR,
just like in an ADC, if I call it a drug antibody ratio, but it's a drug,
I guess, DAD.
And I have two other questions. So the second one is that have you tried to
validate in vitro the mechanism of action of your molecule just
to
see if it delivers by some other effect using, let's say, bone marrow-derived
macrophages? And the last question is do you have a non-irrelevant binding
control? Because macrophages by nature tend to engulf molecules.
So we can see also we have TAMS targeting ADC.
We can see they also take up non-binding isotope control ADC.
Do you have a negative control to make sure?
Yes. So we've done all the target engagement work.
So for instance, and I'm not sure I'm going to answer your question because I
didn't quite get it, but we first take HEC
293 cells, transfect them in with a plasmid
encoding the human
receptor, and
in the control molecules, they do not take anything up, and they do not
express the targeted receptor. Once you've done the transfection, they
take up the fluorescent molecule, and they express the receptor.
We then did it with human monocytes that do not express the
receptor. They do not take up the drug.
They do not express the receptor. When you induce them to
high expression of the targeted receptor, they have
high uptake and high expression. Does that answer what you were asking?
I was more referring in vivo. You only have a PBS control.
Do you have a non-targeting isotope control?
Like an-
Yes. So we've done it with the... Yeah.
We've also looked to see, we took it
without
the payload, and there's no effect.
Is that what you're asking? It's not inducing at least an
immune response in a syngeneic model.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi. Amazing talk. So I want to ask a little bit about the last part of what you
mentioned about moving into clinical trials.
So, and you mentioned quite a few types of cancer that might be
helpful from this therapy. So did you figure it out which cancers
you are going to start with in terms of the clinical trials?
And the second question is for those cancer patients,
which cancer types or mutations, or what particular conditions in the patients
would make them ineligible for the trial?
So
the question is what types of cancers are we going to
initially target?
Yes.
So we are still working on the clinical trial design.
At the moment, the plan is an all-comers trial without
biomarker selectivity to try and enroll as quickly
as possible. When we go into dose expansion,
we are going to use biomarker-driven, and then we will certainly be looking at
sarcoma because that seems we've had really the most
data on sarcoma because of the NCI-supported grant.
We're not going to be looking at brain tumors initially.
Okay, perfect. Thank you.
Thank you so much for the fantastic talk.
My question is,
do you think your delivery system will be affected by the residential
macrophages? And my second question is, do you think the neutrophil will be
another target as the tumor will accumulate a lot of neutrophils?
Thank you.
I didn't understand. I'm sorry.
Sorry. Actually, my question is whether your system will be affected by the
residential macrophages, the normal macrophages?
Are you asking for...
Well, the normal macrophages in the body?
Yes.
Yes. Okay, so you're looking for-
For cell surface
... the potential for toxicity.
Yes.
Yeah. So,
the receptor is
really
expressed most highest in the tumor.
There are certain organs where there is some expression.
There is some in the liver, for instance.
Now, we haven't seen toxicity at all in the liver, which is sort of a surprise.
And we're still awaiting the final results of our
tox studies.
But
if you look at the human protein atlas, it is expressed highly in
the lung, and we don't see any evidence of toxicity in the
preclinical models
in the lung. So there's a lot of work that was done to
size the molecule so that it actually
preferentially gets into the tumor and sort of stays in the
circulation instead of getting into the tissues.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Last question, please.
Yeah. Hi. Awesome talk.
Just one question related to the types of cancer.
Have you considered using the technology into
hematological malignancies?
So,
I was talking to an expert
on hematological malignancies, and I think that it
would have some benefit in ones that have a solid tumor component.
Hodgkin's lymphoma or multiple myeloma are the two that come
to mind. But again, I'm not a hematological malignancy expert.
I would-
Yeah. I mean-
... be interested in exploring it. Yeah.
Mm-hmm. They still can have an issue in the lymphoid organs.
So I think that will be a good idea to try to see if you have anything
there. The other one is, have you seen any
changes in the phenotype
of these macrophages that do all of these things?
Yeah. So,
we've decided that we're just calling them
macrophages that highly express our receptor.
We see them at the beginning, we see them in the middle, we see them at the
end. They always express high levels of the
receptor.
Okay.
And it doesn't seem to change.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. That was really a very nice presentation.
And with this, we're going to be following to our next presentation, Lewis
Barr talking about collagen binding enhancing anti-CTLA-4
therapy in recurrent glioblastoma.
Hello. Thank you for the introduction and the opportunity to speak
today. So our lab primarily
focuses on recurrent glioblastoma research, the most
lethal brain tumor with a median survival of around five
to seven months. It establishes a highly immunosuppressive
tumor microenvironment, and it's one that can be marked by an
increase in regulatory T cells, a T cell
subtype that can directly inhibit antigen-presenting cells
and secrete immunosuppressive cytokines
in the microenvironment. As well as an increase in exhausted T
cells, a dysfunctional T cell state
with limited cytotoxic and effector functions.
Shared between these two cells is CTLA-4, a
critical immune checkpoint receptor.
So anti-CTLA-4 antibodies could be a great candidate
drug for recurrent GBM.
CTLA-4 antibodies have faced some challenges in recurrent
GBM. Clinical trials for anti-CTLA-4 drugs
have shown little to no survival benefit, and preclinical
studies
with anti-CTLA-4 have shown that the drug has
challenges in brain delivery and accumulation within
brain tumors. So new technologies are
needed to selectively deliver anti-CTLA-4 antibodies
to the recurrent GBM tumor.
Our lab sought to identify this
or answer this question by looking at changes in the extracellular
matrix after recurrence. And after
standard therapy of resection, chemotherapy, and irradiation,
recurrent brain tumors can see upregulation of extracellular matrix
proteins like collagens and fibronectin.
This ECM remodeling leads to chemo and radio resistance,
as well as an increase in immunosuppression.
So we hypothesized that engineering CTLA-4
antibodies to selectively bind to the unique
ECM changes within recurrent GBM would enable
localized immune activation within the tumor.
We looked in public bulk RNA sequencing data to identify
changes between the recurrent GBM and normal brain expression
profiles. And what we saw when comparing recurrent GBM to the normal
brain was amongst the most upregulated transcripts was
collagen I and collagen III.
Further breaking this down, we could see that recurrent GBM
compared to the primary tumor and then compared to the normal brain, had the
highest expression level of all three of these genes of
collagen I and III.
We then validated these findings in a few cell lines that our
lab uses. These primary GBM cell
lines were repeatedly irradiated to induce radio resistance in a more
recurrent GBM phenotypeAnd what we found was after this
repeated irradiation, there was an increase in collagen
expression of being collagen I and collagen III, validating
them in the cell lines that we use in our lab.
So collagen I and III are unique markers to
target recurrent GBM.
But we did show that collagen I and III, while not expressed in
the normal brain, can be found expressed in other
organs throughout the body. So a big question becomes: how can we
selectively deliver drugs to collagen I and III
specifically within the brain tumors?
And we accomplished this question with a collaboration project
with Dr Jun Ishihara at the Imperial College of London, where we
used von Willebrand factor, a protein that typically helps to recruit blood
clots to areas in exposed collagen I and
III in damaged blood vessels, inflammatory lesions, and
in tumors.
Von Willebrand factor does this primarily through the A3 domain,
which functions as its collagen binding domain.
So our new question became, if we conjugated this
CBD binding domain to anti-CTLA-4
antibodies, could we deliver the anti-CTLA-4
drug to the recurrent GBM tumor?
To answer this question, we fluorescently tagged our CBD
anti-CTLA-4 drugs as well as the wild type non-CBD
anti-CTLA-4 drug, injected them intravenously, and then looked
at the biodistribution of this drug after 24 hours.
And what we were able to find was the collagen binding
domain,
anti-CTLA-4, had a significantly higher
accumulation within the tumor compared to the wild type,
also showing no accumulation within the normal brain.
We also showed via confocal microscopy that this
accumulation was much more robust within the tumor compared
to the wild type counterpart.
So we identified that collagen binding anti-CTLA-4 could accumulate at
higher levels within the tumor. But how does this affect the
therapeutic efficacy of anti-CTLA-4?
So we did some survival experiments in our recurrent GBM
models. In these orthotopic models, we did
two intravenous injections of CBD anti-CTLA-4, showing a
significant increase in overall survival of
140% compared to the wild type counterpart and
our PBS control groups. Also showing that the tumor size could be
controlled on day 10 as well.
We also used CBD ipilimumab, a humanized version
of anti-CTLA-4,
in our human
radio-resistant PDX models implanted into PBMC
humanized mice. And in these experiments, we identified that CBD
ipilimumab could also extend survival compared to the control,
and also control the tumor size on day 13.
So we identified that the CBD anti-CTLA-4 could
accumulate at greater concentrations or greater within the tumor
and also extend survival. But what was the immune effects leading to
this change? So we performed single-cell RNA sequencing on the
immune cells within the tumor. And in the top panel, you can
see the sub-clustering analysis of the T cells within the
tumor. Highlighted in blue are the exhausted T cells, highlighted in red
are the regulatory T cells. And on the right-hand side, you can see that
in the CBD treated T cells versus the control, there was almost a
complete loss of these exhausted T cells that we saw in the
control group.
But the Tregs, while still reduced, it was unclear whether or not this
reduction in Tregs was substantial.
So we performed flow cytometry experiments to determine
whether or not regulatory T cells were decreased after CBD CTLA-4
treatment, and we found that they were intratumorally.
Additionally, looking at the whole immune cell population within the tumor,
we also found that dendritic cells in their total
proportion were increased after CBD CTLA-4
treatment.
So we did sub-cluster analysis on these dendritic cells to identify
what types of dendritic cells were driving this increase in dendritic cell
change. And when comparing the
clusters between the CBD group and the control group, we found that
this change was largely driven by an increase in these
migratory activated dendritic cells, as well as
CDC1s, both dendritic cell types known for
their anti-tumor effects.
So we identified that the drug could accumulate within the
GBM tumor, it could extend survival, as well as modify the
tumor immune system or the tumor immune profile.
But we wanted to further address the translational
application of CBD anti-CTLA-4. So
we used a human glioma slice culture experiment,
where we took human GBM tissue provided by the UAB Biorepository.
We created slices of these human GBM tissues with a vibratome,
and then we cultured them in media
along with the CBD humanized ipilimumab
for three days. And then after the three days, we performed flow
cytometry to assess the changes in the intratumoral Tregs.
And what we found was that in the group that received the CBD
ipilimumab treatment, we were able to reduce the intratumoral Tregs,
showing the translational possibilities of
CBD in these human GBM slice cultures.
In all, we identified that collagen I and III, while
minimally expressed in the normal brain, are strongly
upregulated in recurrent GBM. And in developing
a collagen binding anti-CTLA-4 antibody,
we found that they could selectively accumulate within recurrent GBM
tumorsThe monotherapy could improve survival in
recurrent GBM mouse models, whereas the wild type could not.
And CBD anti-CTLA-4 could decrease intratumoral
Tregs as well as exhausted dysfunctional T
cells. Our humanized CBD ipilimumab version
prolonged survival in PBMC humanized recurrent GBM models
and could reduce intratumoral Tregs in our ex vivo
3D human slice cultures.
So in all, CBD anti-CTLA-4 could be a promising treatment
for recurrent GBM, and collagen binding technologies can be applied
to multiple antibodies and potentially revolutionize therapeutic
strategies for brain tumors.
And before I finish, I'd like to thank everybody in my lab for contributing to the
research I've shown today, as well as our collaborators and funding sources.
Thank you.
Thank you. Please go ahead.
Thanks for the great talk.
How does this molecule deplete the Tregs?
So does it have the FC component?
Yeah, it's a IgG1.
Okay. Thanks.
Yeah.
Hi, really good talk.
You saw in your, where you see the accumulation of these antibodies, you saw high
levels in the liver. Do you expect any toxicity effects in this if you do a
translational study?
Yeah, that's a really good question and something that we plan on doing in the near
future, really assessing whether or not that increase in accumulation in the liver
is leading to any systemic toxicity. But yeah.
We've seen in previous models, where
CBD has been used, that there has been no liver toxicity, but it
remains to be seen in the model that we're using. Good question. Yeah.
Hi. Great talk. Thank you.
Two questions really quick. One,
I might be wrong, but I noticed that there was a decrease in your Treg
population and your TX population, but it was also accompanied by a slight
decrease in your CD8 positive T cell population.
Do you have an explanation for that?
In the single-cell data?
Yes.
There was an increase in the CD8 population?
Decrease.
Yeah. So
right now, just because of the
amount of cells that we had in our single-cell data, it's really unclear
exactly how many CD8 T cells are changing and what
exactly what type of CD8 T cells they are.
But overall, the exhausted T cells were gone, but it's unclear whether or not the
other CD8 T cells are effector T cells,
cytotoxic T cells, or other progenitor exhausted cells.
So we-
Were you able to look at a cytokine panel to see if
effector T cell activity was up? Just-
Yeah. We didn't-
Sorry I didn't copy it
... in the current study, but that's definitely our next goals.
Excellent.
Very quick follow-up just from a safety point of view.
Have you considered implications during
infections or wound conditions where maybe the
binding would be active and you need an immune response?
Yeah.
Might not be mediated by T cells, but we don't know.
Yeah, that's really good. Since we're using von Willebrand factor and its function
is to produce or help produce blood clots,
it's definitely a big concern with potential, the safety of the drug.
So we've been performing a lot of coagulation assays to determine whether or not
it's affecting coagulation,
as well as a lot of other systemic toxicity assays.
That's great.
Right.
Good luck.
Thank you.
There's a question, microphone number one.
I was just wondering, how does your antibody cross the brain tumor
barrier?
Yeah. That's a good point.
What we think is that in the areas
where the CBD drug is able to enter the tumor
microenvironment are these areas where the blood tumor barrier
or blood-brain barrier is very broken down, has high levels of
these exposed collagen, like how you would see in a wound, and
that's potentially how they're able to enter, instead of areas where there's
intact vasculature. But yeah, that's a good point. Thank you.
And from a clinical perspective, I'll ask you a question.
So how do you expect this to improve, for example, the efficacy of
PD-1, PD-L1 inhibition? Would it be also needed to be collagen
binding, or would you be able to give regular PD-1,
PD-L1 inhibition?
Yeah.
Have you tested the combination?
Yeah. So far in the lab, we have just
used the anti-PD-1 in combination with
CBD CTLA-4,
and we found some minimal increase in survival, but
it's interesting if we could combine that with a CBD PD-1
antibody if that could further improve the therapeutic benefit.
And
do you see this strategy in other tumor types that perhaps have
high expression of collagen, or do you think there that it wouldn't be needed,
this therapeutical intervention?
Yeah. So the CBD therapy
that we collaborated with Dr. Junji Ishihara on from the Imperial College London,
he previously reported that CBD could
improve the accumulation of other immunotherapies in
other, I think, melanoma and breast cancer models. So yeah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
There is a quick online question actually. Sorry. Yeah.
The question is, how have you looked at the kinetics
of the CBD CTLA-4 antibody?
Yeah.
The kind of PK, and how long do they stay in the tissue?
Yeah. We haven't
personally looked at the pharmacokinetics of CBD
anti-CTLA-4, but like I said,
in Dr. Junji Ishihara's initial studies with CBD drugs,
they did do some pharmacokinetic experiments where they found that the CBD
drug could stay in-- They found it in serum
for longer periods of time. But yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Great. So our next speaker is Suraj
Kanchukal.
He's going to talk about DLL3 tri-specific
antibodies.
Thank you for the organizers allowing us to speak.
I'm apologizing in advance. My VP of R&D was supposed to
give this talk, and he had an emergency this morning, so I am
filling in to talk about our
DLL3/CD2/CD3 tri-specific T cell
engager.
As I didn't get a chance to put a disclosure slide together, I
just echo that same disclosures apply
to me. I'm employed at ProBio, which is a member of the GenScript group.
So it should be no surprise to anyone in this room that there is a
large gap in the efficacy
of immunotherapies against heme malignancies versus those
against solid tumor, whether you're talking about TCEs or CAR Ts.
It's especially exacerbated when you look at the complete response
rates between all the different
modalities that go for heme malignancies and the ones that are
approved against solid tumors, including tarlatamab, which I
highlighted there because it'll be the focus of the talk, which is
known as Imdelta, the approved TCE for small cell lung
cancer.
Especially, you see that the CR rate is 1%.
It's actually a little less than 1%.
It's 0.6, so I was rounding up when I made that slide.
And
there's a few thoughts on that, on why it is, including limited
tumor penetration of T cells getting into the solid tumor,
lack of clean targets to go after the solid tumors, the
heterogeneity of the solid tumor themselves
leading to the need for other targets as well.
And the third one is the TME itself causing suppression
of the T cell activity and leading to exhaustion of T cells, and that's where the
focus of this talk is. All of the T cell engagers so
far have been first generation, where you
have one arm against the tumor target and then the other arm against
the T cell target, namely, it's always CD3.
And
researchers in the industry have looked at many ways, and that's what the diagram
on the right shows, to try to combat this issue, including
mostly combinatorial therapies with TKIs or pembro.
But if you talk to any big pharma, especially with TCEs, what they want to
see is single agent activity. So what we're trying to do
to go about that is incorporate another domain there.
If you go back, I put in red costimulation.
So when you look at the interface between antigen
presenting cells and T cells, you have your CD3
zeta signaling as your signal one, and you have a plethora of choices on
what your signal two can be. Taking a cue from the CAR
T world, many people have started integrating in their next
generation T cell engagers CD28 or
4-1BB, and there's also OX40. But there's a few reasons
why we didn't choose to use any of those.
4-1BB and OX40, they're not constitutively expressed
on T cells. They're inducibly expressed, so they're not there
initially when you give the T cell engagers.
It takes a little bit of time for them to get expressed.
CD28,
it's decreased in the exhausted T cells that you find in the tumor
microenvironment. There's also more anecdotal evidence in terms
of CD28 not promoting a stem
cell phenotype for T cells, whereas CD2
does.
In addition to CD2 being constitutively expressed, increased,
and exhausted T cells, there's
also a paper that shows the importance of CD2 in actually
organizing the immune synapse and gathering other
costimulatory molecules in the immune synapse as well.
So we decided to go with CD2 signaling as
our costimulatory in addition to our CD3.
And talking about CD3, when you're trying to make these
complicated tri-specific antibodies.
I like to tell everyone that there's no one-size-fits-all to
TCEs. Your tumor antigens are displayed
in a multitude of fashions, and you're always trying to keep
that about 15 nanometer
immune synapse to maintain optimal T cell
activity. And as a result, you need to change your
antibody configuration. To do so, in conjunction with Legend
Biotech,
ProBio has developed a CD3 VHH from a camel
library. And if anyone has ever done it in this room, you'll know that
creating an agonistic CD3 VHH is very difficult.
We also were able to get cyto cross-reactivity.
Over two years of antibody engineering, affinity maturation, we were able to
get our CD3 into that sweet spot of the double digit to
triple digit nanomolar affinity that people talk about
as being the optimal range for cytotoxicity without
excessive cytokine release. So
since you have a single domain antibody now, it's easier to make all these
different configurations. And putting it together with the
CD2 and the DLL3 binders, we create a two
by two by two format, symmetrical format.
I don't have a picture of it here, but as
we go through the rest of the presentation here, red will represent our
antibody with the CD2 costim, and blue will represent
tarlatamab.
You see in the left column there,
threeThe three different rows are three different
PBMC donors. The left column is cytotoxicity.
You see in all the different donors, we get enhanced cytotoxicity with
our co-stim
T cell engager. And correspondingly, you do also see an
increase of cytokine release, the cytokines that you
typically associate with CRS. But
one way to look at it is that we get effective
cytotoxicity at two orders of magnitude less than tarlatamab.
So you should compare what the cytokine release is
with ours at also two orders of magnitude less.
And when you look at it that way, it's a little more comparable.
I'm sorry I did not put the slides to demonstrate it that way.
But we're getting enhanced efficacy.
We're getting about similar
cytokine release when you
look at the efficacious dose versus efficacious dose.
Why is that?
So this histogram here is
a flow cytometry chart, and going to the left of each of those
charts is increased proliferation.
We put a fluorescent dye within these T cells, and every
time they proliferate, they continue to have the dye but in
half the amount, so it'll go to the left.
So as long as you have peaks to the left, that means more continued proliferation.
Even at a very low dose of our at .01
nanomolar of our
co-stim TCE, you see a large amount of
proliferation versus tarlatamab,
and it also equates to enhanced survival as well.
The right box there is a BCL flow
cytometry, and you see enhanced survival of T cells with our T
cell engager versus tarlatamab.
And this corresponds to
increased persistence in cytotoxicity as well.
Here you have SHIP77 cells. It's
a small cell lung cancer cell line
that we serially challenged human pen T cells,
and we added antibodies at each challenge as well.
And eventually you see that tarlatamab falls off, whereas our
co-stim TCE remains
capable of enabling cytotoxicity, and we believe it's because of its
ability to maintain activation, proliferation, and survival
during that entire time.
When you have a T cell engager that has two arms
that bind the T cell, namely here we're binding both CD2 and
CD3, there is the potential for T cell fratricide,
because one arm can bind a T cell in
trans,
and the other arm binds the killer T cell.
So we assessed whether we get T cell bridging.
When we make our molecules, we make
multiple of them to see which one has the
optimal activity. So we did have
some that showed T cell bridging, where it is binding in
trans, and that's the black line here.
Again, tarlatamab and our lead molecule, the red line,
showed no T cell bridging, and correspondingly, you
don't see T cell fratricide with our molecule either.
That is to say now that the CD2 and CD3 is binding in cis to the
same T cell. Another important factor for this
is whether you get activation independent of
antigen. So here we just have the T cells with no
DLL3, no SHP3 cells, and you see that there's no--
On the box on the left, the top is CD25 levels, and on the
bottom is CD...
I guess they're both CD25, sorry. On the top, it's CD4 T cells, and on the bottom,
it's CD8 T cells. And you see in the absence of antigens,
we don't get T cell activation in either CD4 or
CD8 T cells. And similarly, we don't get that
proliferation in the absence of
antigen or SHP77 cells.
What does this all correlate to, though, in vivo?
What it does is we inoculated these mice with human
PBMCs and these SHP77 cells
on the same day, and then subsequent to that, seven days later, we dosed them
with the T cell engager, either tarlatamab or our
co-stim, our DLL3/CD2/CD3 co-stim molecule.
We do see a larger tumor reduction than
tarlatamab, and more importantly, five of the seven mice in
the red group showed complete tumor eradication, whereas it was
only two out of six in tarlatamab.
In summary, our conventional TCEs armed with
CD2 allows for greater efficacy, even at
low E to T ratios.
It does this, we think, by enhancing the activation,
thereby the proliferation and survival of the T cells.
We don't see trans T cell binding. We don't see T cell fratricide,
pointing to that CD3 and CD2 are
binding to the same T cell in cis.
We see a greater in vivo potency relative to tarlatamab in
rodent models. We
don't have it on this slide because the data is not ready yet, but we
have dosed primates, NHPs, with our
drug, both at one mg per kg and at 10 mg per kg.
They just got past that acute phase, and there's no visible
toxicities. These monkeys are still fine.
When you're thinking of CRS, when you're having enhanced T cell activation,
you usually see that in that one-week time span, but we haven't seen it with
either group of these monkeys at one mg or 10 mg per ml
or, sorry, 10 mgs per kg. And thank you, and I will take any
questions at this time.
Thank you. So in the meantime, I'll ask you some questions.
So regarding the toxicity, you say
that you have not seen any toxicities, but the reality is
regular T-cell engagers
have challenges in the clinic. You're not expecting really more
CRS?
There's always going to be CRS.
Every single CAR T approved product, every single TCE
product has a black box warning for CRS.
I give similar talks about T-cell engagers in the autoimmunity world, where
CRS, it becomes safety before efficacy.
But we believe that in the oncology world, a level of
CRS is acceptable. Even Grade 3 CRS is acceptable because
it's efficacy before safety.
Even pembro has CRS. So
we do expect toxicity. We just want it to be manageable, and we
don't
expect anything beyond what we're seeing with tarlatamab based on our
preclinical data.
Thank you. There's a question there.
Yeah. Thank you for your talk. My question is about your
cis versus trans
engaging.
Is that dependent on the structure of the format?
Have you tried different formats and seen that in some of the format?
Yeah. So
I don't know if I can go back.
The black curve that was on that graph was another format
that we actually built and tested, and that one did bind in tran.
So we used that as our positive control of sorts to show that
we don't want it to have that profile.
So it is dependent on the geometry, where you place the
CD2 versus where you place your DLL3 binder versus where
you place the CD3. So that's why I'm saying antibody.
You have to test a number of formats.
Like in drug development, you have to test multiple formats to see which one
works, and your metrics are going to be different.
Your CRS metrics are going to be different, your efficacy metrics are going to be
different, your bridging, your T-cell fratricide
metrics are going to be different.
So it really depends on what your use case is going to be.
Thank you.
That's why the VHH makes it easier to design all these different formats.
Yeah, definitely.
Mm-hmm.
Just a follow-up on that is
for a T-cell engager to be effective, you have that 15 or
less nanomolar distance. Is the geometry
of your formats also affecting that?
And do you have, in your opinion, found that sweet spot
where your geometry makes cis binding plus
closed synapsis?
I don't have the X-ray crystallography data to
absolutely say that, but that's the theory of why it
happens. Yeah.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Thanks for the great talk. So
you see proliferation of T cells. So there seems to be this dual action,
so
engaging direct cytotoxicity, but also proliferation of the T cells.
So is it possible that the molecule actually primarily works by
inducing the proliferation of T cells?
So mode of action, it would be actually very similar to, let's say, IL-2.
So that would be the main mode of action.
It could be. We haven't tried this supplementing with cytokines to see if
there's a synergistic effect or if your effect is saturated at that
point.
To answer your question, I don't know, but it's possible it could be. Yeah.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Can you comment a bit on your CD2 engager?
Is it
conditional on CD3, or it can just make a bridge between
CD2-expressing cells and our DLL3-expressing cells?
I don't think I underst-- The CD?
Anti-CD2, does it engage on its own, or it requires CD3 to be-
Oh, it can engage on its own.
Okay.
Did you check ever if it
can make the cells to retain in the tumor?
It can make them what?
Cells to retain in the tumor, because you anchored our CD2-expressing
cells-
To anchor them. I mean, to-
In tumor. Anti-CD2 expressing cells.
That's a
study that we're actually looking now to see if the
CD2 is like a... You're asking if the CD2 has an anchoring effect.
Yes.
We're actually looking at that now in terms of whether it's binding T
cells in circulation, because the CD3, as you know,
needs to be a fast on, fast off. So there's no real anchoring
effect. So we're trying to see if the CD2 has an anchoring effect.
I don't have the answer for you yet.
Maybe in a few weeks, I can follow up with you on that one.
Sorry. In interest of time, we are not going to take any questions.
Come find me later if you want to ask questions.
Yeah. Speakers are around, so we can do that. Thank you.
Thank you. So we're going to be following by Orly Richter talking about
the combination of CBP/P300 and the PARP inhibition in prostate
cancer.
Thank you so much for this opportunity to share my work.
I'm a post-baccalaureate researcher in the Shafi Lab at the Center for Prostate
Disease Research, and I'll be talking about our recent work on
CBP/P300 and PARP inhibitor combination treatment.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
And I'd like to start by giving some background on prostate cancer, which is the
most common non-cutaneous cancer among men in the United States,
as well as the second leading cause of death from cancer in American men.
Both normal prostate growth and prostate cancer are driven by androgen
receptor, or AR signaling, where testosterone is converted to
DHT upon entering the cell. It then binds to and
induces dimerization of AR.
AR translocates to the nucleus, where it's bound by transcriptional
coactivators such as CBP and P300, allowing for
transcription of AR target genes, which regulate proliferation,
DNA damage repair, and other crucial processes in the
cellWhen a patient first presents to the clinic with
prostate cancer, the clinician will determine whether the disease is organ
confined or not. If it is, then patients are typically
treated with radical prostatectomy and or radiation
therapy as a first-line treatment with high rates of success.
However, if the disease is not organ confined, patients will typically
be given androgen deprivation therapy, with or without AR
antagonists to target the pathway that I showed in the previous slide.
At this stage, the disease is known as hormone sensitive prostate cancer or
HSPC. And patients on this treatment regimen will typically
see remission for a period of a few years.
However, the disease will eventually relapse, at which point it's known as
castration resistant prostate cancer or CRPC, a
hallmark of which is the reactivation of AR.
So when we look at survival rates for prostate cancer patients, we see in this
primary prostate cancer cohort that the five-year survival
sits over 90%, so quite high. However, if we look at
metastatic CRPC patient cohorts, that five-year survival
drops steeply to below 10% and we can appreciate that this is a
uniformly lethal stage of disease, which is why we're looking for novel
therapeutic options to improve outcomes for these patients.
I now want to go back to the transcriptional coactivators of AR that I briefly
touched on earlier, CBP and p300. We can see
in the earlier stage hormone sensitive disease, most alterations of
CBP and p300 are deletions, shown here in green.
However, when we look at later stage castration resistant disease,
a greater share of these alterations are amplifications, which
you can see here in red, indicating a uniquely actionable role for
CBP and p300 in late stage disease.
We also see in prostate cancer patient cohorts that high expression of
CBP or p300 is associated with shorter survival time,
which led us to ask what the regulatory function of CBP and p300
is in prostate cancer.
To answer this question, we generated inducible knockdown models of CBP
and p300 in a CRPC cell line, the
22RV1s,
and we performed RNA-Seq. We then looked at the down-regulated
genes and performed pathway analysis, and we see that a number of
DNA repair or cell cycle pathways are down-regulated when we knock
down CBP or p300.
To look further into this mechanism, we took a look at the 3,000
differentially expressed genes that were shared between the two knockdown models,
and we ran those through the MSIG database of DNA repair related pathways
and found that CBP and p300 are responsible for regulating a number
of DNA damage repair or DDR pathways.
We see non-homologous end joining, base excision repair, nucleotide
excision repair, and mismatch repair.
And I want to draw attention to homologous recombination or HR, where you can
appreciate that nearly a quarter of these genes are regulated by CBP and
p300.
We also see impacts of the knockdown on cancer cell survival.
So compared to the control, our CBP knockdown reduces cell
survival, and we see a further decrease in survival when we add in a
radiation treatment, shown with the dashed line, indicating that the
knockdown can sensitize CRPC cells to standard of care treatments,
in this case, radiation.
We see the same effect in the p300 knockdown, as well as another
CRPC cell line, the C4-2s.
So what I've shown so far is that in the progression from primary disease
to CRPC, there's amplification of CBP and p300,
which is associated with poor outcome.
This is mediated in part by CBP and p300's role in regulating
HR. So I now want to focus on the therapeutic potential
in targeting CBP and p300 in prostate
cancer. There have been previous efforts to do this, mostly
targeting the CAT domain, which have unfortunately been largely unsuccessful.
So we're now working with CCS1477 or Enobrutib,
which is a compound by our collaborators at CellCentric that targets the
CBP/p300 bromodomain.
So we first wanted to ask if CBP/p300 inhibition has
similar effects to what we see in the knockdown models.
So we treated two CRPC cell lines with the
CCS1477 and performed RNA-Seq.
From the down-regulated genes that are shared between those two cell lines, we
again performed pathway analysis, and here we see that a number of
DDR-related pathways are down-regulated under
CBP/p300 inhibition, which is consistent with what we'd expect
given the findings from the knockdown model.
So this made us ask if there are opportunities for combination therapy with the
CBP/p300 inhibitor, given that prostate cancer patients
have few therapeutic subtypes. Most are treated with a more generalized regimen,
the exception being patients with BRCA mutations who are approved for treatment
with PARP inhibitors. So we looked at co-expression of CBP
and p300 with a number of DDR regulating genes,
and we find that they're co-expressed with PARP-1, a regulator of single-stranded
break repair in both primary prostate adenocarcinoma and
metastatic CRPC patient cohorts, as shown here.
We wanted to test this combination in vitro.
So we set up a comprehensive screen with several prostate cancer cell lines
where we tested the CCS1477 in combination
with the four PARP inhibitors that are clinically approved for use in prostate
cancer. We used a CellTiter-Glo viability readout and
calculated synergy. So here you can see a snapshot of two of those cell
lines, one hormone sensitive and one castration resistant.
And this is a look at the screen as a whole.
So you can appreciate that across all of these prostate cancer cell lines, we
see moderate to high synergy between the CCS1477
and all four PARP inhibitors that we tested it with.
So for our next steps, we've initially moved forward testing in combination with
olaparib, as that's being used in one arm of the
CCS1477 clinical trial in combinationSo we
wanted to better understand the interactions there.
We then moved this into our ex vivo models.
So we use patient-derived explants, or PDEs, which maintain the
intact tumor microenvironment. When patients undergo
radical prostatectomy, we receive both tumor and
non-neoplastic adjacent tissue, which we can subdivide and culture
ex vivo.
This is an example of what one of our PDEs looks like after staining.
We have our control group, the CCS1477,
olaparib, and combination treatment, as shown with H&E staining.
And then we have our Ki67 staining as a marker of proliferation.
This is a snapshot of our cohort. We have PDEs derived from eight different
patients with a range of clinical characteristics.
I do want to note that almost the entire cohort is from African American men, a
group which is highly underrepresented in most prostate cancer patient
cohorts. So we're hoping that the findings from this study can help
inform clinically relevant insights for this group.
Using that Ki67 staining, we looked at percent positivity of the
tumor regions. So I'll walk through PDE1, shown as the square
on here. We see moderate positivity in the vehicle, which is
decreased under single agent PARP inhibitor or CBP/P300
inhibitor treatment, and we then see a full reduction with the combination
treatment. So we term this PDE a responder.
We also see two PDEs which are unresponsive to treatment, shown as
circles on the graph, and several which are responsive to one or the other
single agent therapy, but we don't see a further reduction in the combination
treatment group. So given that we see much more diversity of response
in our ex vivo models than we did in the in vitro, we wanted to explore this
further, so we performed copy number variation analysis, and
we see in the responder that there's a copy number gain in chromosomes
four and 10, as well as a copy number loss in chromosome 17,
as opposed to our non-responders, which are euploid across the genome.
So this is an initial high-level analysis.
We're currently analyzing some whole exome data from this same cohort to see if
we can dig a little deeper into the biological underpinnings of this difference in
response.
Concurrently, we've also been performing the 10x Visium workflow to look at
spatial transcriptomic analysis, and we are again in the process of analyzing
that data, hoping to identify some biomarkers of response.
So our working model at the moment is that untreated prostate cancer cells
will repair single-stranded breaks using PARP1-mediated
repair and double-stranded breaks using
CBP/P300-mediated homologous recombination, both of these
leading to successful DNA repair and cell survival.
However, with our combination treatment, we can limit single-stranded
break repair by inhibiting PARP1, the single-strand breaks then progressing
to double-stranded breaks, and we impair homologous recombination
by using the CCS1477, forcing cells to rely
on error-prone repair pathways or to forgo DNA repair.
So in the future, we're looking to use our spatial transcriptomic
data to identify these biomarkers of response or non-response and to
validate these in our various prostate cancer models.
We're also hoping to expand this PDE workflow to test further
CBP/P300 inhibitors and identify relevant biomarkers to
expand therapeutic options for these patients.
So I'd like to give a big thank you to the Shafeek lab for all their support, as
well as our collaborators and funding sources, and of course, the patients and
families, and I'm happy to take any questions.
So I can start.
Sure.
Thank you. Thank you very much for that very nice presentation.
So I was wondering, in your next steps, how do you
envision to move this? Are you looking for the
biomarker in order to know which patients would benefit from
this combination? And I was also wondering, with all the new
PARP1 that are coming into the clinic, have you done this
experiment, or have you had access to any of this PARP1?
Because there could be some hematological toxicities that could happen with
this combination. So I don't know in what lines you are thinking for the
future.
Yeah, absolutely. We certainly want to use the biomarkers to inform
that decision because it seems, at least preliminarily from the ex
vivo models, that it wouldn't be all patients that would respond to this
combination. And as to the toxicity, that certainly is a
concern, but given the synergistic interaction between the
two inhibitors, we're hoping that we can reduce the dose compared to what would be
needed for the single agent therapy to help mitigate that toxicity.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks. Thanks for the great talk.
So if I understood correct, the primary idea would be to combine with
radiotherapy, so basically induce
pseudotoxic stress and then prevent the cancer cells to repair that
damage. But did you think along the lines of
combining with checkpoint inhibition?
Because presumably, these tumors will accumulate lots of mutations after
you inhibit those DNA repair pathways.
Yeah. We haven't combined this with checkpoint inhibition yet.
We do know that CBP and P300 have some immune interplay.
That's something we want to look at from the spatial transcriptomic data, but we
haven't had as much of a chance to look into the immune interaction yet.
That's certainly in the future, though.
Thanks.
Thank you.
I'll ask one more question. So of course, PARP inhibition goes way
beyond prostate. Are you thinking of doing this in other models,
such as ovarian, breast, et cetera?
Yeah, absolutely. So the CBP and P300 are relevant in other
cancers. The clinical trial for the CCS1477
is also testing in some other advanced solid tumors, and they've
seen advances in hematological malignancies as well, so
potentially in some of those where the CBP and P300 are also relevant.
Since we have time, I'll have quick one.
Absolutely.
So what would be a possible biomarker?
What did you think would be a possible
biomarker for your combination?
Sure. We're thinking other genes that are involved in regulating
DNA damage repair. Off the bat, from the copy number variation
analysis, we saw,
in the responder, a loss in chromosome 17, which is where BRCA1
is. That would be a potential, just since we know that's related
to PARP inhibition already. I don't want to speculate too much without having more
of the whole exome and spatial transcriptomic data, but that's my initial
guess. Yeah.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Great. So our last talk of
the session is going to be delivered by
Aurelie Cadoe.
She is going to talk about the 3D bioprinting.
Good afternoon. Thank you for the introduction and for the invitation.
So this work has been conducted at the Cancer Research Center of Lyon
and at the CRO Anticeneo. So let's talk
about 3D bioprinted cancer models for drug screening.
But first, why do we actually need 3D bioprinted
in cancer research?
So cancer drug screening has mainly been performed using 2D
models and mouse models.
But however, these models have shown some limitation.
Also, 2D models enable the screening of a large
number of condition at a high reproducibility and at a low cost,
they are too simple to represent the tumor microenvironment.
On the other side, the mouse model are very costly and
time-consuming and do not represent the human physiology.
In this context, the 3D bioprinted
technique has been on the rise as a promising approach
to create complex 3D models
with a high reproducibility at a relatively low cost
and in a short period of time.
But how does 3D bioprinting work? The 3D bioprinting
process can be split in three different steps:
preprocessing, processing, and post-processing.
During preprocessing, a 3D in silico model
is generated using different software.
After these important steps, the actual fabrication of the 3D
model can begin. And it starts with the
preparation of the bioink, which is a mixture
with different biopolymers and cancer cells.
In this work, I am using two different types of cell, so
BT474 cell line, a breast cancer cell line,
and this SK-OV-3, an ovarian cancer cell line.
Both of the cells overexpress the HER2 protein, enabling the
use of different drugs, such as chemotherapies
or targeted therapies.
Afterwards, the bioink is then loaded into a
3D bioprinter and extruded through a fine needle
to construct the 3D model in a layer-by-layer manner.
In order to keep the freshly bioprinted models,
they must be cross-linked. Here you can see a picture
of one of my 3D bioprinted model after
biopolymerization.
Several days after post-bioprinting, different drugs can
be added into the medium of the 3D models, such
as small molecules like Taxol or
larger molecules like the ADC TDM1.
And at the end, different analysis can be done, such as imaging,
metabolic activities assay, or flow cytometry.
Here are the results of different proliferation assays using
the three different technique I just mentioned.
So in blue, you can see the results of the flow
cytometry analysis after 3D object dissociation
and cell counting. In black, you can see the results of the
XTT, which is an metabolic activity assay.
And on the bottom, you can see different picture of the 3D
bioprinting model after IHC staining.
And what we can see is that there is an active proliferation up to
40 days within the 3D bioprinting model.
To compare the gene expression in 2D, 3D, and in vivo,
we perform an RNA sequencing. And what we can see is
that several overexpressed gene in the in
vivo model are also overexpressed in the 3D model,
whereas a large number of overexpressed
genes in the 2D models are not expressed neither in
the mouse model nor in the 3D model.
We confirm these results using RTqPCR, where you
can see that the 3D model profile is closer to the in vivo
model than to the 2D model.
We then wanted to characterize the drug sensitivity of our
3D bioprinting model and compare it to the 2D model.
And what we can see here is that for both tested
drugs, the IC values are higher in the 3D model than in
the 2D model.
Then we complexified our 3D bioprinting model by
developing different co-culture models, either by
integrating cancer-associated fibroblasts or
adipocytes. And what we can see is that for
the both co-culture, reduce the sensitivity of
the tumor cell to
both tested
therapies.Finally, we
measured the paclitaxel uptake in 2D,
3D, and in vivo using mass spectrometry.
So first, using the 2D models, we could see
a time and dose response relationship with
rapid
saturation at one hour.
Interestingly, using the 3D model,
after a much higher
drug exposure,
the intracellular concentration did not reach those obtained in
the 2D model after much lower
concentration. And what we can see, we found that the
maximal concentration was reached much later at
around eight hours.
We are currently doing
dosages in murine tumors, but we already
demonstrated the feasibility of this method
in vivo by measuring the taxel concentration in plasma.
And here you can see that after 30 milligram per kilogram
IP injection, the maximal concentration is
reached around six hours, which is closer to the 3D
model.
We want to correlate these
intratumoral dosages with the anti-tumor
activity in the model using different drug
concentration.
So to sum up, the 3D bioprinted models shared more
characteristic with the in vivo tumors than with the 2D
models, as we've seen with the transcriptomic results.
The 3D bioprinted model are compatible with different
cell line, enabling the construction of complex 3D models.
And we are now
doing some experiments to correlate the intracellular drug
concentration of taxel with cytotoxic or
anti-tumor activity and compare it in 2D, 3D, and in
vivo.
I would like to thank everyone who has helped me on this project, but
most of all, I would like to thank you for coming today and for
listening. And I'm happy to invite you tomorrow to come
and see my poster about patient-derived 3D bioprinted
lung cancer models. Thank you.
We have some time.
So I'll start.
All right. Yeah.
So for which type of treatment do you think this type of
modeling is more relevant?
All?
All. Yeah, I don't think there is a limitation.
Some researchers already showed the relevance of this model
for cellular-based therapy, CAR T-cell.
So I think there is no limitation yet.
So I have a quick question. So when you are making this model,
how long it takes to make, let's say, you want to make it
from scratch?
So
you mean just the 3D bioprinting or the-
Yeah, 3D bioprinting.
Yeah. So it depends on the size and the shape of your model,
but in my case, one model
take 1 minute 30.
Do you see any cell death during this process?
Do you see any cell death, like change in the cells when you're doing this process?
No, not during the bioprinting process.
Okay.
And then, you are showing some drug uptake in
the tumor. There's no vessels, right?
So you have these 3D, you are relying on
the diffusion-
Yeah
... of drug to go in there, right? So-
Yeah. Exactly, yes.
Okay.
So the step further, it will be to integrate vascular
vessels using, for example, microfluidic platforms.
But we are not doing that yet.
Yeah. Then how is the drug going down?
Like, you see at six hours it's going up.
You think its metabolism is going down after six hours?
What is the reason of drug concentration going down after six hours?
Yes, it's a great question. Probably degradation
or yeah, we change the medium,
also to keep
the cell viable. So-
But the same drug concentration. Your medium will have the same drug
concentration, right?
Yeah. Right. Yes.
There's a question from the audience.
Lovely talk. I wanted to ask, I saw that you're growing the
3D printed models for 40 days.
Isn't that too many days to leave the model?
Because I do something similar, but I see that the cells tend to
overgrow, and then the viability goes down due to the overcrowding.
Yeah, actually, we do not saw that.
It was just
for fun that we show up to 40 days because it's not
really interesting for drug screening, right?
But no, we didn't see a diminution of cell viability.
We just saw that in the middle of our 3D bioprinting object,
the cell were dying. But
what I was showing you on the
IHC picture is that the
cells surrounding at the periphery of the
3D bioprinting are still proliferating.
Only it was for both of our cell lines.
So, maybe it depends on the
stiffness of your
matrix or your cells, but we didn't see that.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you all for staying.
Now we'll hear Elena summarizing all the talks for
today
Thank you very much. So I thought instead of actually
summarizing seven presentations in 10 minutes, was way
too challenging, I would actually finish with some thoughts from a drug
developer perspective after hearing all of these new advances
and technologies, and thinking how we would be soon, hopefully,
seeing all these drugs in the clinic. So these are my disclosures.
So the first thing I thought was, it's really encouraging to see how
research is advancing in hard-to-treat cancers.
And we need to remember that glioblastoma and small cell lung cancer
still remain some of the most lethal tumors in the clinic.
So the treatment for glioblastoma has not changed for 20 years.
It's hard to think about it. After all of the advances
that we've seen in the last 20 years, we still treat glioblastoma
patients the same, with radiotherapy and just some
chemotherapy. And immune therapy has really still
not changed, in any way, the treatment of these tumors.
So that's why seeing abstracts and presentations such as today
with new CAR T-cell strategies and
collagen binding CTLA-4, it's really
encouraging to see we perhaps can bring the benefit
of immune therapy to glioblastoma
patients. Also,
small cell lung cancer, the reality is the treatment had not changed for over 30
years. Some years ago, we did have the incorporation of checkpoint
inhibition, but that's a modest OS benefit, and it was
really until we didn't have tarlatamab, really the first bispecific
approval in solid tumors, that we have not seen immune
therapy really changing this tumor type.
So that's why the development of more potent
T-cell engagers can also be really very good news for this disease.
Also, we are really starting to see how we are treating the
tumor as an ecosystem, and this is important also for us to
understand in the clinic. We're not going to be only treating the tumor, but we are
really going to start treating the microenvironment as part of the tumor
per se. And these dual strategies of targeting the tumor
microenvironment and the tumor are really going to catch up in the clinic.
So that's why it was exciting to see the GP and MB CAR T
in glioblastoma and this new strategy of this
MAC-TACS bringing into the clinic, bringing the good things of all the
ADC technologies, and also the immune modulation in the tumor
microenvironment.
Finally, as a phase one physician, it is really all about
exposure, about how do we increase the therapeutic window.
So multiple immune stimulatory drugs have
really failed due to a problem of exposure.
So we need to think about the target, but we really need to think about
how we are going to be delivering those drugs.
And retention strategies in the tumor really have a lot of sense in
order to increase this therapeutic window.
And we've seen numerous strategies here today in these very nice
presentations with the lipid nanoparticles circulating RNA
for the IL-12, which is a very toxic
interlocking to give systemically.
Also, the collagen binding CTLA-4 to increase this therapeutic window,
and also giving this MME or payloads
through the
macrophages that are in the tumor.
So really localizing the therapies in the tumor.
Finally, of course, the power of combinations.
Cracking the combinations will be probably one of the next frontiers
in how we treat cancers: to target
heterogeneity, but also adaptive resistance and how we can create
vulnerabilities, as we've seen beautifully in the presentation with the
CBP300 and PARP. And these combinations can be, of
course, two drugs, but with all the engineering that is happening, it can happen
in one molecule. Such as bispecifics,
trispecifics, and we've seen the power of co-stimulations in CAR T,
so it's good to see how this is shaping the field also
probably of T-cell engagers, although I still think we need to
be careful with the safety profiles.
But trispecific antibodies are clearly something that it's exciting to see in the
clinic. And finally, appropriate models.
Many of these advances in the preclinical
arena won't
translate into patient benefit, and this is still a reality.
We really need to improve the confidence on preclinical work, and for
that, we need better models. So it was really interesting to see how
these co-cultures and these three bioprinting models can
better mimic these situations than 2D
models, and it's also for us to learn more about these models.
And with this, I also kept thinking, with all of these technologies and these new
drugs, us in the clinic, we also have homework to do.
We really need to change the way we are developing drugs
and change the way we are developing clinical trials.
And in this very nice review by Lillian Tsui and her colleagues, she
recently published what I think it's a nice way of thinking of
these future clinical trials, where with a patient-centric view
because patient
is coming more to the clinic and the way we design clinical trials, we are going to
be able to incorporate all of this multidimensional knowledge,
both from extrinsic data sources, but also from patient-derived data,
and really perform these adaptive randomized study designs
where we are integrating all of this through artificial intelligence.
So this prismatic concept of the next generation of clinical trials, I think
is going to be very relevant. So with this, I really want to thank all the
speakers for amazing presentations. My co-chair.
I want to thank you for your attention and staying until the end.
I know it's
challenging already many days here in the Congress.
And
thank you all. I hope you enjoy the rest of AACR.
Thank you.
I thought people said it like this by summarizing.